I'm in the business of making soap
spare wash
economic policies
it's like this soap making company are
stuck in their own kind of turmoil with
sales down prices up and an uncertain
future losing customers because of
coffee brexit
inflation everything to then we we
increase in our prices that will be
another thing uh inflicted on them it's
the struggle it's a constant struggle we
certainly didn't need this now not now
not after the last few years that we had
we certainly didn't need this people are
buying less UK retail sales dropped last
month the blue line going up shows we're
spending more but we're getting a lot
less for our money that red line is
sales volumes Falling by 1.4 percent
inflation is making the basics more
expensive and inflation has a lot to
answer for it's also pushed up the
amount of Interest the government has to
pay on its debt last month now at its
highest in more than 25 years government
borrowing was also second worst on
record now we may be getting a new prime
minister next week but the economic
challenges remain the same and there's
no instant relief on the cards
and time is running out even those who
supported treasonomics believe a budget
must come soon but from an economic and
a market perspective it would probably
send the wrong message wrong signal to
postpone that event at the end of
October but again it highlights the fact
that all the components of a budget not
only need to be fully costed but there's
a political Dimension as well as the
economic stroke Market Direction
but it's already too late for some this
Cafe is closing even with energy bill
government support it's not enough
the money that people have got in their
pocket has dropped so their footballers
dropped by 40 in the last few months
um and to compound that our Energy
prices have gone up uh significantly
looking at fivefold increase our supply
chain is also increased in costs so it's
it's a perfect storm really for a
business to close
with a possible recession more of this
could be on its way and with a fiscal
hole to fill
spending cuts too Adele Robinson Sky
News Oxford